I noticed when you came up he's even
playing with a little bit your your
wedding band you are it's not just like
is you're not showy you know it's not
showy it's not like incredibly flashy
which i think is cool
no I guess so we it came with this is
the fact that I'm telling anybody story
so my husband I got married and he got
me beautiful yes a little while ago
thank you thank you one person who loves
that rate one beautiful engagement rate
like stunning stunning stunning but for
our wedding bands for when we got
married I decided to just get them off
of Etsy and so our wedding bands are
from Etsy seriously not listen I've been
talking to you I've been talking to you
for years and I've always loved the fact
that you are frugal you're very nice way
of saying okay you're a cheapskate
but you would see what on etsy yeah I
did cuz I wanted a very very that's like
the thinnest possible platinum band I
mean like my you can't see it but it's
super super thin right there it is yeah
um and then I went and looked at like
how much to everything but there how
much like this is astronomical and so I
went on Ned seems like $90 I was like by
now and then the band that I'll wear for
the rest of my life
$90 everybody yeah
askin actions is $100 so technically his
wedding band was a little bit more sense
he's really pimpin it with his hundred
dollar ban I'm funny I know it when I
went my wife and I when we were engaged
we went to get the wedding rings and she
liked the jeweler was spending all this
time on her ring and we're gonna do this
and do that and do that and do this and
then it was like she's like okay I think
we're done here and I said hey but what
about the ring that I wear and she went
oh yeah and she took out a coffee can
and poured it out and a bunch of these
came out just like this take one yeah
they're like $60 each you put it on and
alright it's not a big deal engagement
ring is beautiful but I don't ever wear
it this ring I'm like six ninety dollars
it's great the poison that she had no
clue whose ring they were making but
they were wonderful and very nice and
polite and generous
you